Here is the surface of the earth.
Above the surface of the earth is air.
Now air is just a bunch of molecules of nitrogen
and oxygen and they are in constant motion
and always bumping into each other.
But all these molecules, well they have a weight
and in fact we can imagine thinking of a
very specific column of air. Let's think of this
column of air here where we filled these imaginary walls
and there is some behind and in front as well.
So we're really just focusing on one column of air.
Now I can actually measure the weight of this air.
I won't explain exactly how yet, but I can do it.
I want to ask you a little question and get you thinking.
Where would the weight of the air be the greatest?
So if I could put a scale anywhere in here
and somehow measure the weight of the column of air
above that scale, where it would be the greatest?
Would it be down here, near the bottom,
or way up here near the top or maybe somewhere
in the middle, choose the best answer.